okay welcome everyone to the orderflows
market analysis for Wednesday April 26
2017 my name is michalos I'm the founder
and Trader at order flows.com the
markets today showed little reaction to
Trump's plan for tax reform which
included cutting the corporate rate in
half to 15% in capital gains by 2/3 to
20% um I think it's a fantastic plan but
um you know the market you know at at
this point it really is what you call a
broad brush with details to be worked
out later but on the surface it sounds
good the Dow was down marginally it was
like down 01 uh
0.1% at uh
20975 the other thing to be aware of is
there's a risk of a government shutdown
going into the weekend that really
hasn't
been moving the markets at least not yet
but um we'll see what's going to happen
there was a big draw in the oil weekly
inventories which couldn't help the
crude oil um and it slips slightly down
to
4925 but before we jump in you know the
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only it should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a Futures Contract or make any other
type of investment decision Futures
Trading is contains substantial risk and
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading pass performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
again why is there that disclaimer I
mean the government requires you to put
a
disclaimer you know on any sort of
investment advice and you know the
reason being is you know people sort of
come into the markets and they think
that this is their golden ticket their
you know the way to transform their life
and you know honestly trading can do
that but you have to understand that
trading takes work it takes dedication
and it's not something that's going to
happen overnight you know I I deal with
a lot of people
that you know come up with a million and
one excuses you know we all have issues
in life um you know we all have you know
I've got a family I've got three kids
you I still make the time to trade to do
other things you know but you know
sometimes I run into people they they've
got a million and one excuses on why
they can't trade you if if you really
want to make
trading your life you have to dedicate
you know you have to find the time you
know successful people manage their time
you know they they go out there they
problem solve you know if their schedule
is so overburdened they rework their
schedule um you know they don't just sit
there I can't do anything because I'm
I'm so busy you know if you really want
to do something if you really want to
learn trading you will find the time you
know it's not something that you have to
sit in front of a screen for 10 hours a
day for the next 5 years and dedicate
yourself that way no I mean you know
when you have the spare time you sit
down you do some analysis you read books
you watch videos you you learn you know
I mean driving in your car you can you
know listen to podcast you could do many
many different things you know i' I've
gotten to the point where on my
smartphone I've got a lot of videos not
on trading but on on other things that I
I want to watch and you know when I'm
waiting to pick up my daughter in school
I'm sitting in the car for 15 20 minutes
you know I could catch up on all that
stuff you know there is a lot of time in
your day that is wasted but you know you
have to learn to manage your time and
and you know and I said if you want to
learn trading you have you can it takes
time but you know what everybody has the
time and it's just a matter of fitting
it into your schedule so you know that
said uh let's jump in the know tools use
in this presentation are the order flows
Trader software which is the volume
footprint chart I'm going to talk today
about a couple of my old indicators the
Delta scalper and the price rejector um
you know I I haven't been touching on
those because actually I took them off
the market but there's been a lot of
people
asking about them um you know wanting
them and again you know I don't want to
be someone that's out there selling a
million one indicators but you know
these are a couple of my indicators I
came up with a couple years ago which
just basically take my orderflow
analysis and plot it on the chart for
you so you know it's going to help your
trading you know help you find more
trades which is um you know what you
want to do you know I hate to say
trading is a numbers game but you know
what if you can increase the amount of
Trades that
uh can be successful then you know it'll
it'll help your trading I know some
people are say oh no that that's wrong
you can't you know this it's uh you know
increasing the frequency is not
necessarily a good thing well you know
what if if your analysis is solid then
increasing the number of Trades is
better you know it's about
diversification um you know the turtles
Right everyone knows the turtles Right
everyone talks about the turtles and
turtles are highly successful why
because they're highly Diversified in
many different markets they do the same
thing but they do it in you know 50 or
60 different Global Futures markets all
around the world you know I said you
know they're looking for you know 80% of
their trades fail and you know 10 you
know border line decent but you know 10
are are home runs so you know it's about
getting more trading opportunities and
you know I that's why I create some of
these indicators is to help Traders find
more opportunities in the market you
know not every trade is going to be
successful but you know what if you know
you 20% of your trades are highly
successful you know very good returns
then you know you want to look for more
of those trades so that said let's take
a look at some charts okay so the first
chart I'm going to look at is the uh
five years it's a four range chart again
I apologize if my voice sounds a bit um
deep deeper today and if I burst out in
coughing is cuz I've I got a bad uh not
cold but some sort of viral infection is
um been working the way through my
system and I get this very bad dry
coffee I get this maybe about once a
year once twice a year um you know I
said I had just traveled back to Asia
from the US and obviously it's very very
freaking hot over here and it's like you
go outside it's 90° at night time even
and you it's go in and out of air
conditioned places and it just uh takes
its toll on the body but um you know so
again if if if I burst out in coffee and
I apologize I'll try and pause it but
uh you know I may have to clear my
throat once in a while as well so anyway
this is the 5 years and you know early
morning 4:36 Chicago time it's all
Chicago time you did have a ratio that
you like 67 you got the price rejector
you got a Divergence
and is it an actable trade yes it is the
only thing I don't like about it is it's
at 4: in the freaking morning um there's
decent volume that's traded in the 5
years now you know take everything in
context as well I don't necessarily like
taking
trades at in markets you know very early
in the morning with very tight ranges so
you know at this time you're looking at
a range of uh 11804 and 3/4 to 118 07
and 3/4 so at the three-point range you
going go from your high to your low in
basically three bars you know you can
Traverse from your high to your low this
one you know so even if you did take the
trade I'm not saying you can't I said
you know I I don't like taking trades
necessarily in tight markets until you
start breaking out um I'm I'm I don't
fancy myself a sort of a a range Trader
you know where you get up to the upper
end of a range and you know look to fade
it to to the lower end of the range I'd
rather have a big move stop and reverse
like that but you know if you're getting
short you know you did come back up and
make a new high by a tick
okay you know if if you're playing with
a really tight stop you know one tick
Above This High yeah you'd be stopped
out okay um again it's up to you I said
I'm not a big fan of taking um trades
you know when you come into the morning
and you look at the overnight
range and it's extremely
small um you know wait for a move to
happen don't try to anticipate the move
I mean you know I don't say don't try to
anticipate the move let me rephrase that
um you know people say oh you're trying
to predict the market no um I'm looking
the market to show me something yes it
is showing me something but I know we're
in a you know compact
range I do expect some fireworks out of
this Market you know I expected it today
maybe you'll get it tomorrow before the
weekend but um you know you guess you
can take the trade again if you had a
one tick stop here above the high you'd
be stopped out I eventually it did come
off but you know we come up here to the
high got another Divergence you you got
the Delta scalper given a sell you see
the Delta starting to pick up again
you're at your high the the other thing
was at this high here at four a very
strong negative Delta which again is is
telling me this Market could be primed
for a bit of a selloff um said we came
back back up in this next bar took an
hour to form you know each of these bars
are taking about an hour so it's telling
you this Market's kind of quiet as
well excuse me but um you it's really
going to pick up activity once the US
session starts around 7 USS rather um so
anyway we start coming off
okay you know 7:00 7:13 you got the the
Delta scaler comes right back in with
the price rejector we bounce up a little
bit now you've got a ratio with the
single print another ratio coming off
coming down into the lows selling IM
balances you know one two 3 four five
you hit this low here so it's a new low
so you broke out of the range that you
were in people say well you broke out up
here yeah it's one tick I hardly call it
a breakout but you know at least here
you got something you got 1 2 3 4 five
um you know ticks so it's a new low so
you know a solid new low rather than one
tick and I'm going to look for something
you know maybe there could be a reason
to buy and what do you got you start
seeing point of control towards the
bottom so you're seeing volume you know
at the bottom of this move you know 2600
1100 you know and you got a Divergence
you got a strong positive Delta 4,000
you don't have a ratio that you like
okay but I often say you know if you
don't have the ratio in that bar on the
low look to the next bar you got it here
5050 six okay and you got some buying
imbalances in there you do have a
selling imbalance okay but it's in a
green bar so um you know I I I look at
that is actually support more than um
you know a lot of selling I mean yes
there is a lot of selling you got that
imbalance but someone's obviously
bidding here um holding the market up is
supporting the market and you know
you're rewarded in the next bar boom it
shoots right up you know from the
uh 05 and 3/4 up to 06 and 3/4 and you
know just continue up and now you're
seeing the points of controls holding
you know I said if this is going to be a
low look for these points of controls to
hold come down here point of controls
holding boom you trade all the way up to
the
highs so this was a nice move from the
lows up to the highs it would have been
a lot more picture perfect if this low
had a ratio but you know it's not there
it's on the next bar though and and I
say you could still even if you don't
have the ratio on this bar with a low
look to the next
bar um
excuse me hang on a sec sorry about that
um but uh anyway
so what starts
happening okay now I have this line up
here this blue line and it references a
level from the day before where you
traded about 30,000 contracts
1809 and you know it held as resistance
basically overnight you know since you
traded that level and since you come off
and I really wanted to see what was
going to happen if we come back up to
that level
and what do you do you come up you get
through it on some decent volume uh you
know
955 but there there's no follow through
if let me pull I'll pull up the chart
real quick just to show you what it
looked like from
yesterday uh to save it where is
it okay this this is yesterday's chart
here so at this level you can see here
in this bar 10,000 8,000
you know
2,900 2,300 you know 2,300 to so this
bar is about 20,000 add another 5,000 so
it's 25 add another
five 30 you know plus these other bars
I'm not going to add up so you know
anywhere between 30 to
35,000 so there was decent buying there
was decent buying in here and again you
know I was looking at this level is is
this going to be a support level is this
going to be a resistance level and it
hel excuse me it held um you know
overnight we
shs we tested it yeah we poked up
through it just because that one tick
through it doesn't mean all the levels
failed you know it it's people think uh
support and resistance has to tick right
to that one price level no you can get
past it by a tick two ticks three ticks
and you know if we react and come back
off of it you know yes it it technically
held not the fact that you got up one
tick through it oh my gosh you know the
the support and resistance level failed
um you know it's it's it's not like that
and you can see it sold off quite nicely
from that level um you know did try to
make a move back up here you've got you
know price rejection with that ratio and
you know it came off down
to not to the low the low was down here
we got uh within about three ticks of
that low came up again um you know then
just later in the day we did have some
5year auctions um we did a bunch of
auctions yesterday coming out uh at 1:00
p.m. was 1 p.m. Eastern I think though
but you know later in the day we did uh
you know we did come back up and you
know just sort of hang around that level
and this is where we were uh in in the
night session when we reopened so that
was the five
years uh let's take a look at the
uh look at the bonds real quick uh sorry
my so you know it's like I got this dry
cough and you know it's
like nasal uh issues going on as well so
it's a bit hard for me to breathe
sometimes but uh you hopefully it's not
something that's going to last too long
so it's been over a week and it should
be getting better soon okay so again you
know 438 very tight range here even
though this is the price rejector I'm
not too interested in it you know again
it's it's 10 tick range more or less at
this time I'm not too excited I'd rather
see some decent uh movement
happening then you know so 7:30 you can
see how you know the volume really
starts picking up um I'll say volume
starts picking up rather the you start
getting some really big Deltas rather um
you got this bar here massive Delta when
I say massive I mean massive relative to
the Deltas earlier you got 2200 minus
2200 Big down bar com to a new low
here very strong Min Delta at one point
the Delta was - 2401 it ended up at -
1206 only and then you start rallying um
here you got a very small Delta 40 which
is not much you know it's kind of
neutral in the sense of of delta in the
bonds and then you got nice positive
Delta here and you know I I expected a
move right up to this high but you know
you didn't get it you just sort of went
sideways but you know I do like this the
sort of structure the way were coming
down in very strong and then you know a
weaker one and then you start going back
up on you know in this case it was a a
minus 40 Delta I would have preferred to
see this bar here this bar here you just
sort of move it all back at where you
have this minus 40 Delta I'd much rather
see it on the low so you're coming down
you know getting weaker weaker then
right on the low you got the weak Delta
of minus
40 when I say weak don't don't be
confused like oh it's it's minus 40 it's
weak no I mean it it's weakening you so
you got very
strong strong you know almost neutral so
it's weakening the selling is weakening
so you're coming down in here and then
you start to move up and in this case
you know you didn't get that you know
the way I like it you sort of got it you
know sort of shifted one bar over and
then that's sort of why I think the
market just sort of went sideways here
you know it's very you know again I
would find this a bit bullish but in the
end you just sort of yeah you did poke
up a little bit but nothing really
wasn't until later that you started
making these new
highs um you know 1050 you got the new
high and then um okay so you know these
blue this blue area here okay this Blue
Area this blue area and even here this
pink area these are the Delta
scalper now again you know it's it's
I'll prob release it again um this
weekend cuz I said I've been getting a
lot of people you know they've been
watching a lot of my old videos and
they're interested in
it and you know the reason I took it off
is because I want to concentrate people
concentrate more on orderflow rather
than just you know indicators that read
order flow um I I think you'll be way
ahead if if you learn how to read
orderflow but again I I realize you know
not everyone has the time to sit down
and and stare a charts all day long or
you know or have the inclination to want
to but you know that's fine you know
everyone has their own uh reasons but um
you know it's giving you a Bice it reads
the Delta you know it it tracks the
Delta over how many bars and you know
the price action
now this notice the difference here so
it's given a buy here it's given a buy
here what do you have here you got a
down candle okay you got a red bar you
know so it opened here closed here this
one's a green one it opened here closed
there when I was putting this one
together it's the Delta scalper I really
prefer to just have it read the Delta um
you know for as as the main part of its
analysis if you were to go
to the indicator this thing ah it's slow
um it doesn't have it in there but
um I didn't make the distinction on you
know to trigger it if as long as you
know for a buy the bar has to be up or
for a sell you know the bar has to be
down I I didn't put that in there
because you know what I at the end of
the day I still want to make a decision
um you know based on what I see in the
market structure now if I see a Buy
Signal and the candle is red meaning the
bar closed lower than where it
opened I wouldn't take the trade you
know if I'm taking a long right I want
the bar to be going up up not down like
this one here it's going up not down you
know this is a red bar this is a green
bar so you know people say oh you know I
took this trade and failed well why' you
you know at the end of the
day they said you know I hate to say I'm
an old school Trader but you know I I'm
the type of Trader I I still want to
make the analysis myself you know really
what these indicators help me do is you
know say hey idiot don't miss this trade
it's setting up for a potential buy or a
potential sell but then when I see
what's happening in the bar I I wouldn't
take it you know this one I would be
more interested in taking than this one
cuz I know the market is going up it's
confirming it this one is not it's going
down and just as on this this cell here
you know this is a Delta scalper here
given a cell and you know it's a red
candle and it's working its way down you
know you're coming off a a red candle
here you got a red candle here okay you
know that that's a that's just like you
green here green there now here you got
green and then red you know if this was
a green candle I'd be all over it but
it's a red candle so I'm not that
interested in
it and you know again it's it's these
are not the most massive moves it was
kind of a quiet day but you know there's
there's ticks to be had in
there then you know the other thing I
just you know other one I'll just talk
about real quick you this is the price
rejector here this red line and again it
reads the
Overflow it reads for rejection in
prices you know areas of price rejection
so when I see this I know at this point
in time this red line it's telling me
there's some price rejection up here yes
we came right back up and you know made
a new high okay so that failed you it
started to sell off you know who knows
what happened you know you went from
this bar 1024 to 1046 where it changed
you know early in this bar it look like
it could continue selling off you know
that the price rejection here would hold
in this case it failed um then here this
bar this green line This is the price
rejector again it's telling me you know
there's price rejection down here again
it's reading the order flow over the
last several
bars and and in the current bar
and you see how the market reacted you
know it went up so you know there's
price rejection there um just looking
for another signal
here you ended up with this next bar
here doe um which for me in order flow I
I find them
very um what's the term neutral in a
sense in my my own analysis that's why
there's no ratios above or below
it um you you see you got the price
rejector there and you know it just went
sideways over the next couple hours
before going up and then you know later
price rejector again and you know came
off a bit then just sort of went
sideways there um in the evening session
that's where we are right
now all right so the next market I'll
I'll discuss here is soybeans um this is
July beans and people say oh beans uh
you know beans suck uh you know I don't
want to trade beans you actually beans
is is a great contract to
trade and you know I think beans have
probably made more millionaires Traders
up until about 10 years ago than any
other Market um you people don't believe
it when I say that but
uh you know most of the young kids today
they they don't uh appreciate the
history of of the markets so to speak
but um you know if you're older older
fellas if you remember when you're a kid
the phrase means in the teens
um but uh anyway I digress you know read
a history book but again you so you had
the price rejector right on the open
here 8:30 is is when the market reopens
for the day session I'm not a big fan of
taking any sort of signal right on the
open um yeah there's just a lot of
going on at that time with uh the order
flow let the market settled down but
anyway um you know so we're going back
and forth back and forth and we got up
to the high you know someone asked me uh
today in the room do
you start your I do you look at the the
overnight highs and lows if of course
you have to um you know the highs and
lows yesterday overnight in the agent
session you made your high in the beans
um 968 and a half and you know watch
what happens when you get up there
during the day session you got up within
a tick of that high you couldn't break
through that high you got point of
control in this bar up near the high and
you're seeing some strong volumes up
there 300 um 387 you know
104 and look at that volume compared you
know here you had some decent volume um
you're going up but you know most of
these bars here these red candles you
don't have this type of volume up there
um you know at all um you know 174
240 I'm looking at the red candles not
these green candles but you know so it's
telling me you know point of control
again up near the top up near this
high so there is some stopping volume up
there um you know it's not a ratio it's
three but um you I can see the volume is
is decent it's decent and then we just
start this major sell off actually um
you know it just starts picking up it's
like a Snowball Effect
um you got 26 Delta here and then it's -
26 - 55 - 56 - 500 - 172 -
777 you know now you know sound balances
are really starting to pick up and this
is you know a solid move it's not like a
boom very fast move like a number came
out you just sold off 10
cents you know this high is at 1024 down
here is 1124 so this is over an hour
it's a gradual you know consistent
selling more selling you know more you
just I look at this you know these bars
are never positive Delta it's all
negative on all Min Delta there no Max
Delta so it's just consistent selling
and you come down into low again more
imbalances and then look what happens
you hit the low again you know this is
your low that you made in the overnight
session you know when you hit that low
overnight session there was very decent
volume down there you know 600 300 you
know over 1,000 around that low between
961 and 960 and a qu
and then look you just power right
through it 282 749 177 it's a stacked in
Balance strongest Delta of the dayus 12
31 and it's just going lower next bar
Lower some more strong negative Delta
boom powering down into the
lows boom boom boom you hit this low
here and you know it's your first green
bar and you're thinking you know hey you
I'm the type of person is this a reason
to buy I don't know yet let's let's see
how this this shakes
out excuse me it's not a ratio it's a
Divergence though I mean you know don't
just buy every single blind Divergence I
say blind I mean you know every single
Divergence that appears without any sort
of confirmation because what happens the
next bar you got a bearish ratio bearish
ratio and you boom you make new lows you
three in a row actually which to me is
is a setup that I like but again you
know it's coming after a monster move
literally from your highs up here at uh
I mean what was that high 968 or
something like that 968 and a quarter
you know all the way down to 9 um you
know
56 or S you know 956 and a half I'll see
you get three in a row you just had a
12C move and you're getting a a short
setup I'm not a big fan of that you know
I take things in context you know if I
was getting a buy setup down here yeah I
would love it because I I would love to
have a reason be buying at the lows not
a a reason to be selling at the lows
after a 12-cent move um you know you you
can you do get these sell setups higher
in the day you do get buy setups at the
lows um you know just because you you
got a sell setup know read it in context
of the market don't just take it because
hey I got a sell setup but and just you
know forget that you just had this big
move um
lower so anyway so you got this resells
you know boom boom boom you get bounce
you get the green candle here which is
what I like up to this point of control
now the the only thing is I know we get
down here it's a ratio bounds low which
indicates some stopping volume am I
looking at it it's not the the heaviest
volume it's
136 you know 22 95 you got unfinished
business there everyone's go hey you got
unfinished business here we're going to
test this low and we do
actually you test it you got another
Divergence you got a single print you
got some buying and balances now you
know this is very interesting you have a
ratio bonds low you test it again so you
got a double bottom you got a single
print this
time and you got much less volume you
how do you read that well you traded 136
here on the bid then you just trade five
so you got less selling going on here
obviously he's only five Lots sold into
this low to me that's a sign yeah that's
a sign
that sellers are done they got no more
left to sell and what do you see you are
seeing
some other Bottom Feeders like myself
coming in and you know aggressively
buying you got buying and balance buying
and balance buying and balance buying
and balance buying and balance Delta is
starting to pick up here you know you
had the 128 here 193 503 and you know
you just pop up here up to you know the
959 area but you know really this bar
here this one at 1250 again it's it's
we're going into the close right5 is is
the closing time you you don't you're
not going to have much capacity for
trade because we're not you know don't
expect us to all of a sudden go you know
at 1250 25 minutes ahead of the close
all the way up you know put in a 10-cent
move um it's more more likely just going
to get a little bit of a bounce and go
sideways honestly you know so if you get
a couple cents out of it hey a couple
cents is not bad you know it's quarter
uh one tick is uh 12 and a 12 bucks so
one cent move is you know it's 50 bucks
if you get you know one or two cents
it's 50 or 100 bucks contract so it's
decent uh we just sort of go sideways
you know after after this bar here you
we get a little pop up here come down
you a little bit move up just sideways
and then um you know we have closing the
day around 956 so you know right around
this
level but this
was this was a a much better trading
opportunity than this three in a row
here you know it's just because you know
hey you know maybe we're we are getting
a bit of Bounce we are seeing some price
price rejection down here I said even
though this is a three in a row setup I
like I don't like where it's appearing
you know you got to take you know take
things in context of the market and
again you know respecting the overnight
highs and lows when you come down into
the new the lows that you made overnight
here and you traded you know thousand
contracts there what's going to happen
are we going to blow get through this
lows I I do expect there to be more
volume down there and there is and you
know we power through it strongly um
very little bu we didn't spend much time
here you know look at this bar this is
1158 1158 so it just it happened really
fast you know even the next bar 1201 So
within um you know within 3
minutes you just blew right through that
level so yeah you got to respect these
highs and lows I mean you know like I
said I was explaining to someone I used
to be a breakout Trader these are the
type of breakouts you like you know not
these little half-hearted ply ass
breakouts where you break out by and
make a new low by two ticks and you you
retrace back five six seven ticks and it
just sort of go sideways this these are
the breakouts you like to trade but
that's not my style of trading
anymore uh so I'll jump into the e-
minis real quick here okay so this is
the e- mini it's a four range chart as
well um you know all the charts I've
been showing you to our four range
charts so you know people ask do you
jump your charts you change your charts
around a lot no I mean you know most
markets I look at I always look at four
range charts whether it's beans whether
it's uh bonds five years you know snps
there are markets that I use wider you
know more volatile markets such as uh
NASDAQ da eurocurrency crude oil I use
eight
range but I don't really you know look
for you know the most perfect chart you
know if things are going to appear
they'll appear whether it's on a on a
four range chart or a 10 range chart or
an eight range chart um you know I still
look for the same things they they still
manifest in in the different types of
charts so S&P is you know going back to
the 8:30 session or 8:30 the 8:30 Cash
open this was
a price uh Delta scalper here give a
little bit of sale but it's it's ahead
of the cash so I'm not too keen on it so
830 where are we here this is 8:30 here
Market just does nothing it's very very
tight range again this morning coming
into this
uh coming into this cash open then you
get down here 846 price Delta scoper
give it a buy and you know we get a nice
little move up you get up to this bar
here and you know you got the binding
balance on the top that's why you got
this red arrow you got point of control
right on the top you got ratio bonds low
which to me this is a I like to call
high percentage trade but what happened
nothing it just went sideways on you um
you know you run up here price rejector
price rejector and when when you start
seeing some bearish signs and your
Market's not selling off
don't sit here and trying to fight and
keep shorting the out of it because
you're getting signs that hey the market
should be selling off and it's not so
when the Market's not
doing what your analysis is telling you
to do and your analysis is wrong you
know you're it's not the Market's wrong
your analysis is wrong that you're
thinking hey we should be selling off
you know I'm I'm going to sell some more
sell another one you know I took a loss
here I'm going to sell two this time and
you know double up and and I don't have
to catch as big a move you you do that
that's the quickest way to the PO
house so you know really what you know
when you realize your analysis is wrong
you get out of the trade and I said you
know you're seeing you know a bunch of
signs here the market should be selling
off and it's not and what happens we
start making new highs boom again you
know this you know relative to what I
was talking about with the um soybeans
just now you know when I said you know I
used to be a breakout Trader I hated you
know this is where i' get killed days
like this we're breaking out finally you
know um and what happens you make a new
high by two ticks and then you pull back
um you know from two 2388 and a half
down to 2386 and 3/4 and you're like you
know how much heat can you take you know
before it goes back hey he makes a new
highs um and then just goes sideways on
you but you know
later um you know the move that you saw
in the uh soybeans where it just blew
right through it in a minute and kept
going lower those are type of breakouts
you like unfortunately you know you
don't you don't know when it's going to
happen um I say you don't know but uh
you can have an idea by reading the
order flow you know if a move is going
to be strong or not then we got up to
this point here um 10:00 I remember this
uh you know we're in the room we put in
this massive heavy volume I say massive
volume but heavy
volume
39,000 okay and I I remember looking at
this high at this time you you got these
two imbalances which is what you like to
see when you're making new highs you
like to see buying imbalances
and you had a very strong Delta here um
you know again I'm sorry uh you
had 1,000 3 and a half th000 and here
4,000 and the market you know when I see
this I expect the market to explode
actually and what happened nothing it
just went sideways on you you know I was
really looking for the market to move
higher off this you know I was kind of
worried that you know we put in this
heavy volume and we're not going higher
but you know at they selling up here um
there sellers up here again we're not
that far off from our our lifetime highs
just below I think it was around 23.98
or 98 a half and we're just going
sideways here but you know you got the
negative Delta here but it comes back
and you got some nice buying and
balances you got three here one two
three another one here and boom we
started going back up to the high it's
just sort of you know it the the sellers
here had to get exhausted um you know
they had to be satisfied that they sold
all they wanted to sell you know that
all the inventory they wanted to move
onto the buyers they're able to do it so
they are they were you know it's quite a
quite a lot and then eventually you
started making these new highs again you
know decent Deltas 1100 3,000 3,000 you
know 1100 3,000 again and then you get
up to this High here look at this
negative Delta 3,000 okay this bar here
yeah it's strong 1,800 here you know
3,000 I don't want to say it's getting
weaker I mean 1800 still quite strong um
you know if this was 600 I would say
yeah it was getting weaker but you know
1,800 honestly is quite strong doesn't
look that strong when you look at you
know 3,000 3,000 but you trust me 1,00
is strong and right at this High you got
a very strong negative Delta
376 follows up negative Delta 1800 you
have a Divergence not a ratio that you
like and
then ratio ratio stack selum balance
negative Deltas you're all up here at
this highs all negative Delta right
right so and the stacks on a balance and
a couple ratios indicating you know
prices up here are being
rejected and then look another one see
already you got three in a row okay so
you you got a bunch of stuff going on
here you got three in a row again it's
three in a row off a high right remember
we just talked about
soybeans where is this three in a row
going into the low I'd rather take it
three in a row off of a high not three
in a row one two three going into a low
what what would you rather take if
you're looking to get short where would
you rather get short off the high or at
the low honestly I'd rather get short at
the High um you know people say oh it
doesn't really matter no it does it does
matter um what's your capacity Your
Capacity is trade from your your high to
your low and make new lows rather than
have a 12 cent
move into the lows be at your lows and
expect another 12-cent move I think is
is more ridiculous
but you know people will argue with me
but you know just go back to your
trading forums and go back to your
simulators I said I've been trading the
markets long enough i' I've seen a lot
of things and you know this bar here you
did get the pullback at one point it was
green um you had to Max Delta of
669 and again you know for this three in
a row setup you're looking for an entry
point between the two points that
controls of the second and third bar
right here but again really you should
have been getting short off this stack
selling a balance
off this
high and again you got another thing
here you got the ratio after the stack
selling a balance I love those it's a
very high percentage trade and you know
we start moving down
2391 boom you know all the way down in
here to you know
23 uh what is that 86 86 and a half so
you know that was a decent move and you
know is it something that if you're
patient and does it happen every day no
it doesn't happen every day but but you
know if you're patient you know what to
look for again you know would you rather
be taking a setup like this off the
high or you know getting short or like
in the soybeans I just showed you
getting short going into the low um you
know again that's a decision you have to
make um but that was like literally I
think the most
beautiful uh you know trade opportunity
for the day now you a little bit later
again you got another stack bu in
Balance again the high is up here at 94
we had just been you know we going up
you know sold off a little bit got swing
low here up to the swing High starts on
off three in a row again you don't get
the pull back here on your
entry and down here you get the stack
buying and balance so you you went from
a swing High area down to a swing low
and you know it's about a force Point
move yeah it's a stack b b and balance
four levels 1 2 3
four and can you take it yeah of course
you can take it I mean it's a little
it's far enough away from the high you
still got some room to move you know
from your in this area if if you're
projecting it to go the high honestly on
a four range chart I'm happy with uh two
points three points not two ticks to
three ticks two points which is eight
ticks minimum um you know so you do get
something you know 90 and a half up to
90 around 92 and a half does pull back a
little bit before making another run all
the way up here
again honestly I'm not looking for this
move it would have been nicer if it
happened straight rather than come up
here pull back a little bit and then
make that move but I I know myself on on
a four range chart anywhere between two
to three ticks you know once we start
pulling back down that's where I'm
looking to bail out a little bit but um
we do trade up here we get with a tick
of the high again you got a ratio there
you don't have a
Divergence you know it's it's a positive
Delta
still and you do have a ratio indicating
some price rejections you got you know
this blue number here it's indicating
price rejection that's the ratio that um
I use in my
analysis and we started selling off
again and it's aggressive you know it's
uh three selling IM balances in this bar
then you got a big stack selling balance
and this is right around you know the
earlier it was
23895 you know here it's a little bit
higher but again it's coming in off the
high you just come up off the high you
see some signs of price rejection and
you know maybe you know you got the
price rejector kicking off you got a
ratio that you like you know if you're
not convinced yet you should be
convinced down here get short and again
you know it's a decent move 90 and a
halfish area 90 and a quarter down to
you know below 88s so there was some
something to be had
there but those were um you know in the
snps those those were some of the more
decent trades I don't want to go over
every single bar today but um this video
is quite a bit
long and so anyway I will end it uh you
you know for for this session this
session this recording so thanks for
taking the time to watch this you know
some people will say ah you make no
sense but um you know for those that are
able to discern my ramblings hopefully
you got something of value in this video
and to learn more about trading and the
software that uh we
developed for trading with orderflow um
go to my website www.or flows.com and
thanks and bye-bye